comment nous avons fait pour résister
pendant 7 ans en entrepreneuriat
7 ans dans un univers se met dans le bus
et de défi
certaines se demandent notre volonté ce
que nous voulons apporter comme valeur à
l'édifice du continent comme beaucoup
d'entre vous nous avons tous une
histoire surtout professionnelle
la mienne commence en 2015 2016
en 2015-2016 je venais d'obtenir mon
baccalauréat donc j'ai débuté on m'a
orienté plutôt au sein de l'Université
Internationale collège
mais étant un fan un discutable de tout
ce qui est animation vidéo
je me suis beaucoup plus battu pour
obtenir un stage au sein de la Radio
Télévision nationale que nous appelons
RTG
donc pendant que je faisais ma première
année à l'université
j'alternais en quelque sorte et que je
faisais je partais faire un stage au
sein de la Radio Télévision nationale
dans la catégorie infographie l'année
qui a suivi
je suis allé me présenter aussi j'ai
déposé mes dossiers au sein de la radio
privée évasion Guinée en deuxième année
j'ai obtenu mon second stage et j'ai
commencé là-bas dans la section
infographie finalement ils m'ont même
proposé un contrat
tu es à l'issue de ça après plusieurs
observations que j'ai compris que je
pouvais apporter beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus pourquoi
pendant qu'on nous apprenait à
l'université le html et le CSS
j'évite compris
dehors les gens utilisaient plutôt
WordPress pour faire quelque chose de
professionnel
pendant qu'on utilisait à l'université
Paint ou Movie Maker pour des vidéos
j'ai vite compris que dehors on
utilisait After Effects ou Première Pro
c'est à dire de grands logiciels
standard et j'ai remarqué qu'il n'y
avait pas de prérequis il fallait pas
avoir un diplôme pour pouvoir commencer
à apprendre
donc après mieux réflexion j'ai décidé
de former une équipe une formidable
équipe d'ailleurs et nous avons créé ce
que nous appelons reytech
rétex c'était quoi rétex était tout ce
qui était spot vidéo pour des
entreprises des solutions de gestion
pour des entreprises et aussi des
applications pour entreprises on était
diversifié
qu'en 2017 que nous avons réussi à créer
notre première solution innovante que
nous appelons ride event
était toute première solution qui
permettait de gérer tout ce qui est
événementiel dans le pays c'était la
toute première application de gestion
d'événements en Guinée en gros avec vous
vous connectez vous vous inscrivez il
vous localise et il vous dit les types
d'événements qu'il y avait aux alentours
avec
vous pouvez exporter les événements dans
vos calendriers si vous voulez souscrire
un événement vous souscrivez ça vient au
calendrier le jour J vous avez un rappel
on avait rajouté une autre touche
d'innovation d'arrêt de vente que nous
avions appelé l'environnement 360 s'il y
a-t-elle événement à Canal Olympia par
exemple et que vous ne savez pas à quoi
ça ressemble on avait intégré l'option
360 l'utilisateur pouvait voir à partir
de son téléphone à quoi ressemblait
l'intérieur par exemple du canal Olympia
et l'une des plus grandes innovations
sur le ridevent était le système live
event on avait intégré le tout premier
système live d'événement en direct vous
souscrivez à un événement vous ne pouvez
pas participer à un événement à l'aide
de l'application vous avez la
possibilité de suivre cet événement en
direct
et ce qui faisait encore beaucoup plus
innovant on n'avait pas de grosses
machines ni de grosses caméras non on
avait deux ou trois téléphones là et là
on avait un système réseau et à partir
de là on pouvait retransmettre cet
événement en direct nous l'avons
expérimenté avec le concert du rappeur
français qui était venu Booba on l'a
expérimenté avec le festival du fer et
aussi avec des concours organisés par
l'incubateur sa boutique
mais
comme pour beaucoup d'entre nous ça n'a
pas fait long feu il faut l'avouer
ça n'a pas fait long feu pourquoi
nous étions
nous étions pressés
et on ne connaissait rien du tout ce qui
était stratégie on était juste concentré
que sur l'aspect technique
pour exemple la nuit où nous avons
réussi à finaliser l'application et que
Google Play nous a autorisé en disant
que oui l'application est éligible pour
nos stores c'est ce jour que nous avons
lancé la communication comme ça sur les
réseaux il y avait aucune stratégie
c'était pour dire oui on a lancé un truc
innovant et puis ça s'est limité là
on ne savait pas comment rénumérer c'est
à dire comment gagner de l'argent avec
on avait aucun plan de communication
c'est quand ça venait en tête on
communique et surtout on n'avait pas un
bon document de présentation pour
pouvoir attirer des potentiels
ça a été un plus pour nous
mais on avoue qu'on avait beaucoup de
déchets on était jeune et nous avons
commencé à prendre nos erreurs parce que
avec toute cette technologie derrière il
y avait un coût il y avait le coût des
serveurs et beaucoup de choses surtout
concernant le live la connexion Internet
et tout ceci
donc nous avons accepté que ça soit une
défaite
et nous avons continué à chercher
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons proposer
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons donner au
public
et c'est dans ce cadre lors d'un voyage
à boufa la préfecture de buffa
pèlerinage
que mon papa je lui ramène hommage qu'il
y a un amoureux généralement de tout ce
qui est histoire recherche nous envoie
sur un site
et ce site c'était Dounia
nous partons à Doumbia et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé à Doumia il y avait un guide
touristique qui nous accueille à Doumia
et qui nous dit
ici c'était un port excusez-moi du terme
c'était un port négrier c'était en
se dit oui c'était là que nous on venait
rassembler des esclaves pour les
transporter
donc déjà je connaissais pas qu'il y
avait Doumbia je savais même pas qu'il y
avait le nom une préfecture où je
croyais un village qu'on appelait Domia
mais ce qui m'a encore le plus marqué il
dit que ce port que vous voyez derrière
a transporté plus de personnes que l'île
de Gorée
ce port que vous voyez derrière était un
grand carrefour incontournable de tout
ce qui était transporté
je n'étais pas au courant et de loin si
nous observons l'île de Gorée avec Dakar
ça rapporte nous voulons tous aller à
l'île de Gorée pourquoi pour se sentir
rapproché de nos ancêtres on voulait
voir comment ça s'est passé tandisk en
Guinée
qui a transporté plus c'était la
première observation
j'ai filmé j'ai demandé l'autorisation
de filmer le guide a accepté il a donné
ses explications il a tout expliqué il a
vu que c'était en ruine et une seconde
observation c'était quoi
on ne sait pas que ça existe
on est là pas dans nos livres d'histoire
il n'y a pas d'excursion pour les élèves
étudiants et en dernier lieu tout était
en ruine il n'y avait plus rien ni avec
eux des débris des débris il n'y avait
plus rien
la rentrée maintenant
comment on appelle ça
au studio au bureau avec
j'interpella mon collègue et je lui ai
expliqué
j'ai dit on a vu ça il y a eu ça ça
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons faire pour
améliorer et c'est là il y a eu
plusieurs idées on peut faire un
documentaire que nous allons lancer sur
les réseaux sociaux on peut faire ceci
on peut faire cela mais nous on a voulu
faire un truc dans la durée
et c'est là on s'est dit pourquoi ne pas
reconstituer ces endroits en 3D pour
pouvoir les conserver pour des
générations futures
au moins si c'est reconstitué nos
enfants qui viendront au cas où il n'y a
plus vu que c'est en ruine grâce à la
technologie ou à la réalité virtuelle on
pouvait voir au moins à quoi ça
ressemblait c'était ça le but
et au fur et à mesure on se dit ok
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire derrière ce
que nous pouvons faire derrière
c'est de créer
un jeu vidéo et je tiens à préciser
qu'on avait aucune base de connaissance
en jeu vidéo rien on s'est dit on va
créer un jeu vidéo
d'accord on crée un jeu vidéo on se
lance on dit d'accord quel type de jeux
vidéo nous voulons créer on s'est dit vu
qu'on évolue dans l'animation 3D
pourquoi ne pas se lancer dedans
finalement on a accepté on avait un peu
de sous nous avons investi dans la
formation des jeux vidéo et nous avons
commencé à créer ce que nous avons
appelé African Heroes avec africaniros
nous avons eu à créer beaucoup de choses
on a eu à faire quelques tests et à
l'issue de ce test il y a eu un premier
résultat
ce premier résultat nous a donné
beaucoup beaucoup de comment je pourrais
dire
d'espoir c'était pas top comme au début
on manquait cruellement de matériel donc
on s'est dit on va continuer on était
fier du premier résultat on était même
pressé pour poster diffuser le jeu mais
nous avons appris de l'erreur de 20 ans
on se calme nous faisons des recherches
le bench et on va trouver une meilleure
stratégie pour mieux faire valoir ce que
nous avons comme projet
donc
nous avons continué ainsi et il fallait
investir dans le matériel et les
licences où il fallait trouver l'argent
pour acheter le matériel adéquat pour
pouvoir ressortir quelque chose de
potable
à l'issue de cette formation nous avons
continué continué continuer nous avons
continué notre prestation en quelque
sorte et nous avons pu ressortir quelque
chose d'extra nous étions fiers
maintenant du résultat du contenu et on
s'est dit là nous allons voir ce que
nous pouvons donner
donc de nos jours si la régie le veut il
y aura une vidéo derrière qui monte à
quoi ressemble le jeu africain Heroes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc on avait intégré le système là
et nous avons ajouté des mythes il y a
beaucoup de mythologies
on s'est inspiré de la savane à quoi ça
ressemble
[Musique]
avec un guerrier nous avons vu beaucoup
beaucoup d'aspects
[Musique]
donc
en gros nous avons fait ce qu'on appelle
des techniques de reconstitution nous
sommes allés chercher un peu partout
dans le pays
ok c'est juste ça va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci donc en gros c'est tout un
ensemble que nous avons vu on a vu
l'environnement nous sommes allés
chercher des histoires au Bénin en
Afrique du Sud avec Shaka Zulu avec la
reine Angola angolaise nous sommes allés
au nord avec les Pharaons nous sommes
allés un peu partout même au Kenya pour
récupérer les histoires les cumuler et
pouvoir sortir un scénario plausible où
chaque Africain puisse s'y retrouver
c'est ça africaniros
pour conclure j'aimerais dire quelque
chose
ce que j'ai vraiment appris c'est bien
de faire des choses en grand nous les
jeunes nous sommes des rêveurs nous
avons beaucoup beaucoup de rêves mais il
est encore meilleur de les adapter aux
réalités du pays
quel que soit l'application que vous
créez l'objet que vous utilisez adapter
les réalités du pays
c'est vraiment la plus grande erreur que
nous faisons surtout ceux qui quittent
qui partent aux États-Unis et en France
qui voient qui a une application qui
aide les jeunes à faire ceci se disent
oui je vais venir faire ça en Guinée il
y en a pas sans savoir qu'il y a des
problèmes ici qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
pour l'adapter ici la connexion Internet
est-elle comment je peux dire accessible
facilement on va prendre un exemple sur
la gestion d'école est-ce que nous
pouvons créer une application de gestion
d'école publique sur un établissement ou
il n'y a pas d'eau de courant où il n'y
a pas de table ça complique donc adapter
vos applications ou réalité du pays
pour terminer ma science spéciale à une
personne qui était là dès le début qui
ne m'a jamais lâché qui continue à
arriver et même si je lui dis et si nous
fabriquons une fusée il dira ok il y a
pas de souci allons-y c'est mammoutou
Touré il est dans cette salle et
j'aimerais que vous l'applaudissiez pour
moi s'il vous plaît
ayez des partenaires comme Mamoudou et
des personnes que vous pouvez appeler à
deux heures trois heures du matin leur
expliquer vos soucis et le lendemain il
soit à votre porte ils disent oui on
trouve quoi comme solution il était là
il a fermé les yeux sur beaucoup de
choses la première version à 2h 3h du
matin ça m'a énervé je suis allé dans
option j'ai supprimé le jeu tout le jeu
complet je le dis j'ai supprimé il dit
pourquoi je le dis bah c'était pas le
design n'était pas ça il ne sait pas
énervé il s'est pas dit ouais c'est une
perte de temps il dit ok il y a pas de
souci tu as quoi comme solution je dis
un investi dans les machines et puis on
revoit encore il y a pas de souci alors
il s'est investi coréen et nous sommes
toujours dans la partie
démonstration du jeu je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]